so I think if you told me a couple years
ago that we get a sequel to rage I
wouldn't have believed you but here we
are the 2019 rage comes out in like a
month less than a month now I think and
Alessandra you and I got to play a
couple hours of basically the full game
there was still kinks they were working
out but it was essentially the complete
game
but yeah I mean like what were your
first impressions when we walked in and
played it yeah well um this was actually
my I guess my third time playing the
game um I actually played I'm pretty
sure the same demo you did it was just
like set in like a you know just like a
building and you know you go through a
tutorial then you would go through like
a very standard combat encounter and I'm
gonna be honest I really wasn't that
impressed considering like they made
such a big deal of trying to bring him
rage back you know because you know the
original game I guess was something that
you know there was a lot of hype around
it like you know this was first the the
first its software open-world game and
they're trying to you know very much
like bring that sort of like heavy
action from like you know from doom or
you know like any of their previous
shooters into like a broader open-world
but I feel like it just didn't really
work and it seemed like everyone forgot
about it but you know now it's back and
we got to play like you know very
substantial amount of the game I guess
like what up two and a half hours I
think er yeah three hours and they
basically let us go everyone they ran us
through a light tutorial yeah and then
they dropped us in an arien they're like
you can pretty much go wherever you want
and they load us into a late save where
you can kind of see all the
experimentation and combat that you get
which I thought was really neat but you
saw what you saw rage it was like kind
of like what all isandro is describing
was very linear and like mostly yeah it
was basically a tutorial intro to combat
and then a horde mode and then just a
brief like race that we could try which
was about and now we're and a half I
want to say so I kind of came away with
what Alessandra just expressed like
that's it there's no more to it and I
was a little disappointed a little
worried about what the game was going to
be but both of you seem to have much
more positive impressions of the game
now having played a later version of it
yeah so I hadn't seen much of rage 2
other than like some of the previews and
whatnot but yeah I had fun it was it
definitely seems like a playground it
the combat like people have said is a
lot like doom but more expanded a little
more it fits that open space a bit more
there's a little bit more mobility
some interesting powers you can get like
the ground pound in particular was
pretty fun because that would like
nullify any falling damage so if you
jumped off the high area you take a lot
of damage but if you did that ground
pound you'd stop that basically feel
like a superhero
playing this game pretty much and like
that's one thing we noticed there was so
many skill trees in that game it was
almost overwhelming with how many skill
trees there were now that's a bad thing
it seems like there's a lot of
customization like each weapon has like
except several like different upgrades
you can acquire like some that like you
actually hit through multiple enemies
like you know like increasing your
spread and each weapon also changes when
you activate the overdrive which is when
the game gets for one gets a lot more
colorful like you know the hunt they
they put like this really bright and
like you very like very pink filter over
the like that the game and like yeah
yeah I mean it's a very it's a very
colorful like post-apocalyptic game
which again just shows like how much of
a difference it was from this game is
from the original game which is very
much one color it was like brand-new
shades of brown and gray yeah but it was
it was just really exciting getting to
actually explore this world because um I
feel like that's a common thing to say
when you're talking about open wolf game
it's really exciting to be able to
explore the world but um but again I
just keep going back to like you know
thinking back to the original game which
is very like you know I guess especially
in retrospect very boring like a very
boring open-world game but this one is a
very exciting one because there's a lot
more personality for a lot of characters
your character in particular Walker who
can actually you know you can choose
either male or female with this
character which is very interesting and
you know you also interact with these
other like you very yeah very
interesting like colorful characters as
well really
he's got to see this place goddamn
ranger Jersey shredded with caution here
make sure you got the gear and the
skills for me like you know just
especially thinking back to those old
demos like a I feel like I've done sort
of like a 180 like in my opinion is like
totally changed which doesn't really
happen that often
especially when you sort of preview like
games like this where you know usually
your opinion you have sort of like maybe
grows a bit or it just stays the same so
I'm very much like you know interested
in seeing like the more this game I am
curious to ask you both about the open
world because when I was playing rage -
it was basically just going from point A
to point B like there was no radio
stations to listen to the side quests I
kept running into like they would all
start with the same line of dialogue
with like this old man would be yelling
at these people that they were chasing
him then I would go bid him more and
then it would be the same old man
yelling again so is does the game kind
of mix that up a little bit more like is
there life to this open world it's hard
to say like from based on what we saw
there there are things that happen in
the open world for instance I was
driving around and someone challenged me
to a race so we just did a quick race I
got some experience or whatever there's
like there's a lot of fights going on
and I could be driving on that we
factions that are fighting each other
that you can get involved in there's
also convoys that drive around
[Music]
but yeah you look at it and it seems
like there are there is stuff to do in
this world whether or not you're gonna
want to spend a lot of time doing that I
don't know like yeah from what we saw
I'd probably mess around with that stuff
for the first five or six hours and
after that I'd be like all right let's
just do the let's just run the main
quest or the main story which is also
kind of interesting how they're dealing
with that because it's very it's it's
very nonlinear and then you're
completing different quests for
different different people and that
moves your I don't even really know
you're stuck with like the different
factions
it kind of reminded me of via like Ghost
Recon wildlands where you'd like go to
this area complete those missions and
build towards this boss care to do that
you fight we didn't see enough of it to
really say whether or not it's exactly
like that or not yeah but it definitely
seems kind of like that where you can
kind of tackle these missions however
you and I think another interesting
thing that they mentioned was that they
plan on updating this game pretty
regularly yeah the Tim Willits actually
described this game as an evolving like
single-player game you know it's not a
live service game and the I mean that's
something that should be clear that's
not it's not like destiny or like you
know and you don't know you don't need
to be online to play the game you can
play it you can like clear through all
the content like you know it's not
cooperator no there's no there's no like
multiplayer of any world itself will
change yeah they described it as like a
live events like being gradually like
incorporated into the game like a you
know say like a there's I don't like a
roaming like band of bandits like like
scouring through like certain regions
and you have to go find them or whatever
and they didn't really dive into like
you know I guess when or like when
exactly or liquid what sort of content
but they did say like you know the game
that would be at launch would be very
different from the game that's gonna be
out and like maybe a year from now
whatever so it's it'll um I don't mean
like in a lot of ways it seems that this
game is very different from like what it
has done like in the past it's like a
proper open-world game now and a lot of
that has to do with the fact that this
is co-developed by Avalanche which you
know they
Just Cause and you know of course they
made a you know Mad Max so obviously
their perfect fit for this type of like
you know post-apocalyptic open-world
game so yeah and it is running off the
avalanches engine - it's not it's not
within tech that makes sense because
you've got this big open world and you
need an engine that can handle the
abdomen also there's there's a lot of
linear missions that feel very much like
doom yeah in the building so it's a lot
of very narrow hallways yeah yeah they
actually called them like those missions
like these dungeons I guess you can say
like direct callbacks to a court or
shooters so I think that of the time
that I play with the game those moments
are my favorite because it allows you to
experiment with your powers a lot more I
was a little worried when they announced
that this game was going to be a
single-player because it's not co-op
like has an easy comparison Borderlands
then it's harder to mix and match powers
because then you have to worry about
cooldowns but when you're in that kind
of very narrow space setting up those
awesome combinations is a little bit
easier and so I'm a little bit wary that
of the very outdoors the battlefields
and I'm kind of wondering since you guys
both play the later game how do you
manage like distance and again like does
it get easier going forward because
there were moments where like I just
wasn't able to - far enough or my powers
weren't able to reach far enough in it
slowed the game down a significant
portion I felt like I was able to keep
up with lot of enemies like you know and
in terms of like you know just like
doing like the park or just platforming
like oh we had a double jump as well and
and like if you get your your combo
meter going you can just keep spamming
your overdry up which is what all
isandro dinner you just see like what
you did it like five or six times oh
yeah oh and just slaughtered you're just
tearing through enemies like it the
combats like really it gets like really
chunky and gross and laughs but that
might have been my detriment because I
only had access to the assault rifle
yeah and shotgun so you're not the most
creative weapons that are in that game
and I've seen the trailers I'm like at
the gravity gun and like the pistol you
can snap your fingers neck
blow it into fire looks so cool yeah it
definitely seems like momentum is good
like now when you start moving and once
you get that momentum rolling it feels
pretty good but maybe when you start
outt it's tough too there's not as many
ways to get that momentum rolling I
don't know any closing thoughts on yeah
you know just uh I feel like I'm just
like I was saying earlier like a you
know my opinion of the game has just
changed you know because uh it's really
Chao understand that it's really
challenging just sort of like a you know
sort of demo these like open-world games
like you know and sort of small doses
like even like spending like an hour or
so like I feel like that's not enough
time to actually you know be able to get
a sense of like you know all the systems
you know of the game and seeing how that
old means how the old mingle together so
you know but I mean after spending two
and a half hours like I was just I I was
just so impressed with like you know the
amount of detail but also just like the
amount of like a you know content within
the world like you know it just seems
like you know there's a little bit of
something but you know to do like when
it when it comes to vehicles like you
know participating in races or you know
actually clearing out bases like you
know with the enemies like gangs or
whatever is oh I'm still a little bit
worried about it but what you both have
said today has made me look at the game
a little bit better so I'm looking
forward to it a little bit more kind of
repeating what Alessandro said I think
the humor is one of the best things that
rage to has going for it and I
completely understand that
now the borderlands 3 coming out the co
rage to you has direct competition but
rage to just seems to be embodying a
completely different style of humor and
I really want to see where that goes
yeah I think a lot of people will like
it I I don't think it'll necessarily
blow people away from what we played
that could obviously change because it
does seem like you have a map and you're
kind of just checking things off which
is meditative in great and in like the
combat itself is a lot of fun from what
I've laid yeah but but yeah I as someone
who wasn't really looking forward to it
much after playing this demo I'm pretty
excited to play rage too
[Music]